[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
17 feed culture de la musique un lieu
culturel rénové ou encore une plongée
dans la vie d'une actrice et chanteuse
emblématique du 20e siècle
voici le sommaire un voyage ludique et
poétique pour mieux connaître marilyn
monroe jusqu'au 30 novembre l'esprit de
l'icône glamour des années 50 s'empare
du prix smaïl en cours dans le cadre
d'une installation transmédia intitulé
update marine abus que le théâtre des
arcades s'est refait une beauté avec une
scène a grandi ou encore des sièges
rétractables la salle de spectacle
propose une saison culturelle pour toute
la famille une partie des auditions pour
la cinquième saison du tremplin des voix
s'est déroulée le week-end dernier à
magny les hameaux
ce concours de chant organisé par
l'association la voix en scène a réuni
une cinquantaine de jeunes talents une
mise à jour poétique ludique et non
conformiste de marilyn monroe c'est ce
qui vous attend jusqu'à la fin du mois
de novembre aux prises mahé long cours
peut-être marilyn au vous plonge dans la
vie de l'icône avec notamment des photos
inédites
[Musique]
à la fois drôle sensuel fragile ce sont
toutes les facettes de l'actrice et
chanteuse glamour qui sont exposés aux
prises mahé long cours peuvent dette
marilyn a été imaginé par la compagnie
principe actif
objectif faire revenir marilyn monroe à
notre époque et des clichés pris par
l'un de ses photographes officiels
milton greene ont été réintégrés dans
des photos d'aujourd'hui c'est son fils
joshua green qui a resterait tous les
négatifs de son père avec sa société
archives images et nous a confié ses
photos et ses photos nous les avons
réintégré dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
elles viennent se mêler alors ça c'est
en exclusivité c'est vraiment pour pour
le pour le prisme des photographies de
la collection personnelle de jeu
chagrine piétons qui ont été restaurées
qui nous a fait tirer sur papier
japonais et qui sont imprimés à les
tâches du théâtre avec jamais exposé ses
photos tous les recoins du lieu culturel
ont été investis par ces composites au
cours du parcours le public peut
également découvrir le témoignage de
l'épousé de milton greene
l'idée de cette exposition est de
balayer les idées préconçues sur l'icône
des années 50 et de lui rendre hommage
elle était représentée par le hollywood
comme étant extrêmement sexué avec une
image très très glamour et puis c'était
quelqu'un qui avait une vie intérieure
extrêmement riche qui est extrêmement
fine cultiver féministes même nom mais
quand même
une installation qui se veut ludique et
interactive avec notamment un jeu sur
smartphone
le public est également mis à
contribution c'est pas juste une expo où
les gens viennent et puis regardons ils
peuvent s'impliquer
donc s'il voit marilyn cela suivante ont
dévoyé marelli mme dans votre cuisine
dans votre librairie n'hésitez pas la
photographier de nous envoyer la photo
parce que marilyn viendra rejoindre
l'exposition
cette exposition fait partie d'un
dispositif transmédia le 30 novembre le
public pourra découvrir sur la scène du
prisme sa confession inachevé seul texte
autobiographique de l'icône glamour du
sport dans un théâtre c'est ce que vous
propose le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 26 au 28
novembre prochain un spectacle assez en
solide que nous présente le directeur de
l'établissement lionel masse et à c'est
un collectif qui appelle le collectif
colette qui met en scène un spectacle
qui s'appelle 100 m papillon et que je
conseille absolument à toutes les écoles
de natation en deux mots le comédien qui
sur scène va faire son autobiographie il
a été un joueur de haut niveau
et puis à l'âge de 20 ans 21 ans
à force d'entraînements la de la
natation on sait que c'est un sport
absolument harassant tout d'un coup il
ya un découragement
pendant une heure il va nous faire le
parcours entre sa passion pour la
natation
entre les entraînements harassant et
puis cette façon dont tout d'un coup ça
ne fonctionne plus il sait pas pourquoi
il continue à s'entraîner comme un
forcené
et pourtant ça ne marche plus ils ne
sont plus l'eau donc c'est véritablement
un projet un spectacle de théâtre /
pourquoi et comment les sportifs de haut
niveau arrive-t-il à s'infliger et à
accepter cette souffrance et pourquoi un
moment cette souffrance devient
intolérable
d'aller manger
mais non vous pouvez vous passer par
cette source
[Musique]
sacrifice implication on garde la
technique
et en os x comme déchets
pl harrison
depuis le mois d'octobre les bus poids
peuvent profiter d'une salle de
spectacle qui a fait peau neuve
profitons de l'intersaison à la commune
a rénové son théâtre des arcades
une scène a grandi des sièges
rétractables découverte des nouveaux
locaux des loges avec un accès direct à
la scène c'est l'une des principales
nouveautés du théâtre de buc la salle
utilisée depuis une quarantaine d'années
s'est refait une beauté
c'est attaquer vraiment aux problèmes de
base c'est-à-dire refaire toutes les
parties et perches
tout ce qui est électrique avoir deux du
matériel neuf et récents donc voilà et
puis bien sûr essayer de l'amortir en
évitant tout ce qui est de location
puisqu'avant au loup et pas mal de
matériel et l'idée c'était de mobiliser
tout le potentiel de la ville pour
partir dans cette aventure culturelle et
surtout donner une identité culturelle à
la ville de buc donc ça a commencé tout
petit on a mobilisé les artistes les
partenaires les sponsors la ville ya mis
beaucoup un million d'euros de travaux
ont été engagés sur l'intersaison la
salle qui reçoit des artistes depuis
2018 a vu sa scène à baisser et agrandi
plus de 300 spectateurs peuvent assister
aux 35 dates qui font vivre la saison du
coin des dates bien régulière notamment
des événements qui sont récurrents
aujourd'hui à buc l'idée étant d'être
vraiment éclectique de répondre à tout
le monde nous aimons accueillir les
familles nous aimons et cueillir le
jeune public nous aimons accueillir les
jeunes
donc on essaie vraiment de répondre à
tous les goûts les prochains rendez vous
seront magique solidaire et drôle une
trentaine de dates est proposé au public
le théâtre espace coluche a plaisir à
accueillera le 30 novembre prochain la
chorale eurocorps cette formation
chrétienne européenne est composé d'une
centaine de jeunes chanteurs et
musiciens
ils viennent de france d'allemagne de
suisse ou encore de roumanie ils
interprètent des chants traditionnels et
contemporains en plusieurs langues
on découvre plein de gens on discute on
apprend à se connaître les différences
entre entre les pays et tout ça dans
autour d'un but commun c'est cette
chanter la paix la joie et d'avoir
autant de jeunes en fait ensemble s'est
fait quelque chose de peu commun et
c'est ça qui est moteur qui nous motive
tout ça continue de chanter dans cette
chorale le concert à plaisir sera
l'occasion de démarrer la cession des
concerts de noël
on essaye de mêlée l'ancien et le
nouveau et d'interpréter ça de manière
dynamique pour que ça soit cohérent avec
ébats des choristes qui les chantent qui
sont jeunes
vous aviez découvert cette formation
unique dans cette émission il ya
quelques semaines le quatuor à cordes de
l'armée terre continue sa série de
concerts rendez vous le samedi 27
novembre à 13h à satory pour un moment
musical en rapport avec halloween et
réservations obligatoires à l'adresse
qui s'affiche sur votre écran du champ à
présent avec la cinquième saison du
tremplin des voix à magny les hameaux à
l'oral aura lieu le 1er février 2020
mais des auditions de présélection avait
lieu samedi 16 novembre à l'estaminet
je te regarde dans mes papiers je change
de la chine
moyen
et à
une cinquantaine de jeunes talents ont
participé à ces présélections organisées
par l'association l'avoir en scène
on essaye de vraiment d'avoir cette
particularité d'avoir de laisser libre
cours à l'univers de chaque personne
voilà l'univers t2 à l'univers de chaque
artiste est donc pour ça on a un groupe
auteur compositeur interprète sans
limite d'âge sans fin qui va de 9 à 99
ans et puis à côté de ça on s'est dit il
faut vraiment différencier les moins
deux saisons qui ont une voix pas encore
souvent muet et les plus de 17 ans qui
ont une voix déjà affirmé et voilà
qu'ils savent déjà vraiment ce qu'ils
veulent donc on différencie ces trois
groupes pour avoir vraiment un panel
assez large c'est une grande voix qui
nous a quittés il y a un an aux hommages
à charles aznavour le 1er décembre à
l'abri blues à bois d'arcy c'est à
partir de 17h à noter que les profits de
cette soirée seront reversés à l'afm
téléthon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous habitez à saint quentin en yvelines
et vous cherchez des idées de sorties
voici une petite sélection avec tout
d'abord monsieur de pourceaugnac à la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt
ce sera le 29 novembre il s'agit d'une
comédie ballet de molière sur une
musique de lully
le même jour le 29 novembre il y aura de
l'humour à la mairie satrape avec trappe
un profane lycée le rendez vous annuel
de l'improvisation
l samedi 30 novembre à la batterie de
guyancourt les studios auront du coeur
vous allez retrouver johnny montreuil et
didier wampas sur scène une soirée
originale car pour participer à ce
concert pas d'oublier mais un jouet neuf
qui sera ensuite est distribué aux
enfants qui en auront besoin
et puis toujours le samedi 30 novembre
le chanteur tété sera en concert à
l'espace albert camus à maurepas
voici un avant-goût de ce qui vous
attend je vous tiendrons bon monsieur de
pourceaugnac que je suis ravi de le voir
simon 6-2 torse diack monzie qui doivent
beaucoup grattements à dissoudre marche
amplement qu'il est retenu et si vous
avez tous et mes parents et pour ça j'ai
fait disparaître le tas
[Rires]
entonnant des formations ça sera fait
[Musique]
lundi dans ses mocassins
marie ça caille dans ces jo
emilie
thual siffle
m
tél
jean suite a lancé midi
m
poésie des grands
les gants c'est le débit commentant des
concerts de
on termine cette émission avec cette
soirée de lancement de l'association
manic oise le cinoche ce sera le
vendredi 29 novembre à 20h 30 à
l'estaminet avec le film astérix et
obélix mission cléopâtre on le rappelle
le principe de cette association est
bien c'est de permettre à tous les
habitants d'aller au cinéma dans leur
ville
donc vraiment retrouver cette ambiance
de ciné club on va pas commencer avec
les films qui seront à la fiche et au
fur et à mesure que l'association
on va avancer on pourra peut-être
proposer et des films à la fiche et des
films qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
au cinéma dans un cinéma classique pour
quelqu'un de normal ou qui ne pas qui
n'est pas étudiant ça sera donc 6 euros
sa place pour quelqu'un de moins de 26
ans ça sera donc 4 euros et pour les
adhérents car oui vous pouvez adhérer
pour 10 euros à l'association comme ça
ça nous permet de nous de notre côté de
pouvoir assurer financièrement les coûts
de production de projection des films
pour un adhérent sa place sera à 3 euros
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]